You can access the underlining NumPy
array within a Pandas data frame
using the values property.
But you can also create
NumPy arrays from scratch.
There are many ways to create an array.
Let's start with creating a one
dimensional array from known values.
NumPy has an array function
which can convert most
array-like objects into an n d array.
What do we mean by nd array
is n-dimensional array.
Let's see how this works for
Python lists.
To start with,
we need to import the library numpy.
And we rename it as np for
the ease of use.
Next, we simply call
a function np.array and
pass a list which has value [2,3,4].
Note that this function
can take as input a list,
a template, or other sequence.
Check out the documentation for
the array function and nd array type for
more information.
Now let's see the output.
The output you see here is not
a list but it is an array.
Let's go ahead and create a 2D array.
Now if you want to create a 2D array,
we simply pass in a sequence
of sequences to this function.
Each tuple enclosed in round parenthesis
serves as one row in
the resulting array.
We could also have
passed a list of lists.
This is called sequence of sequences.
Let's go ahead and print it.
Here is the output and as expected
there are two rows and three columns.
This function is mainly useful when you
have a list of sequence of values, and
you want to convert
them into NumPy arrays.